Hi, I'm Deadpool the other jolly guy in a red suit with a Lapworth sitting on here to tell you happy holidays.
In the spirit of this most festive time of year
I've decided to release my holiday cheer all over the world so sit back hold on your ornaments ghazal a little eggnog
At least that looks like eggnog and prepare yourself because it's time for Saint Wade to put the wind
In winter wonderland
*coughs*
Happy holidays everybody the Deadpool 2 marketing campaign has started and just like last year they're doing is many
Ridiculous things as possible you probably remember all the Christmas stuff
They did that was just the beginning like the 12 days of Deadpool
They also did a bunch of crazy Halloween stuff there was the Mario Lopez promo where he literally punched him right out of his chair
Fuckin Slater. April Fool's Deadpool will of course be rated R. It's ok Jessie, Slater can't hurt you anymore
The big difference this year is the Deadpool isn't coming out in February
It's coming out in June so the marketing campaign has just started a little bit later
If you're just finding me for the first time be sure to subscribe to get everything
It'll be a lot like when we were getting ready for the first Deadpool movie during the holidays with all that funny stuff that dropped
And I'll be doing giveaway stuff for the Deadpool movie, too
So I'll explain that at the end of the video. By this time last year
We'd already gotten the first couple of Deadpool trailers
So what they've done is they've sent out some select issues of a Good Housekeeping magazine
With Deadpool on the cover just hyping up how to cook your Thanksgiving turkey
And all these good
Housekeeping tips like you see this poster here with the main actors, you even see a Stan Lee cameo in the background here.
The way they're explaining
It is that you can't go out and buy this issue like they literally took it to a bunch of press outlets and a bunch
of people
but they actually took it one step further and had it written as if
Deadpool were writing this big feature about how to carve your turkey
So there's a little too much
Text for me to read it like it would literally take me 20 minutes to read all the stuff
He's written
So I'll just read the intro and explain what the other pages are but you see on the cover
Deadpool stuffs our holiday issue how to be a holiday superhero
You'll go crazy for D's Nuts, giving your family the bird
Turkey tips come for the gifts stay for the package as it
You know just making as many jokes as possible the letter reads a Wade with words
Deadpool's holiday letter dear readers skimmers and those who generally only look at the pictures when Good Housekeeping
Called and asked me to be a contributor to their holiday issue I was completely shocked and flattered. I'm a huge fan
It's always been a dream of mine to visit the Good Housekeeping mansion and bathe in their infamous, grotto
There's a joke about the Playboy Mansion because they have a grotto where a bunch of naked people just hang out all the time
But unlike most men I read Good Housekeeping
For the articles like another big Playboy joke there was no time to waste
I immediately jumped off my show pony kiss my agent Bernie and grabbed my ink quill in case you weren't aware
I freaking love the holidays and not in the like a friend way either. I love the holidays in the same way
I love stuffing a turkey using the two most important ingredients of all heavy eye contact and lust
it's that bewitching time of year where we can reflect on the last 11 months using Christmas cards from friends and family is a
comparable gauge of our own levels of happiness
Stephanie and Adam went to Palm Springs Janet finally got her GED
Uncle Kevin drank a gallon of sangria took off all his clothes and walked into the ocean forever
But whether your Yuletide memories are of gorging on nuts and creamy clams (see my holiday recipes)
getting your tongue stuck to the flagpole or
Simply watching papa pool carve some perfectly plump poultry in order to give everyone the bird
There's no denying that the holidays are the most wonderful time of year
So sit back grab a mug of cocoa and cozy up in your favorite chair
It's time for this naughty little stocking stuffer to unleash his holiday cheer ;)
Xoxo Wade so that's just him letting you know that the Deadpool 2 promotional
Campaign has begun like we're gonna start getting trailers and teasers throughout the rest of the year
But it is funny to see the level of detail that they go into with some of this
Marketing like there's actually a lot of thought that goes into this so they actually do have
Instructions for how to carve a turkey were you basically why cutting off a bunch of your limbs like you can see him slowly
Carving the turkey up he accidentally cuts off a couple of his fingers like down here
It says by now your turkeys torso should resemble "middle-of-the-movie" Lieutenant Dan. If you guys haven't seen Forrest Gump
He basically has no legs which means it's time to clip your beautiful bird's wings like a Pegasus at the glue factory
So just like we did before find the wing joint poppet slice
Separate and BAM! nice work Emeril so really like all these different instructions. They're all just metaphors for sex
It's just the way that Deadpool would turn everything into an innuendo
The funny thing about D's Nuts and creamy clams skinny dip is that they do have legit recipes
So I'm gonna clip these out and paste them here you can pause the video if you want to copy these recipes down because you
Can actually make these eat the nuts and drink the cream make as many jokes as you can about eating Deadpool spiced nuts
And drinking his creamy clam skinny dip, but just to be clear even though
They're trying to be really funny about giving him a blowjob these are actually legit recipes that you can make
But let me know in the comments. What do you guys think about all this obviously
This is just tipping the hat to the crazy stuff. They're gonna be doing this year
It'll be just like last year if you remember all the weird promos that they did they did prostate exams
They did a pool log during Christmas like it was literally just hours and hours of Deadpool with a log
*Choral Singing*
But the big difference this year is that we have cable, so they might work him into some of these funny promotions, too
And then beyond all the funny stuff
There's the regular trailers and teasers
So those will drop between now in the end of the year now the main reason why they're doing this is a Thanksgiving
Issue is is because Thanksgiving is getting ready to come up in the United States
But they might also release a trailer in the next couple of weeks too because we have Star Wars coming so they might try to
Attach the next big trailer to Star Wars when it comes out in December or before the end of the year
But there'll be other stuff beyond the regular trailer, too
So if you were subscribed to me way back when Deadpool was being promoted like two years ago around this time
It'll probably be a little bit like that
But because the movie is a little further out they might not release quite as much marketing
But I think they're gonna try and take
Advantage of the holidays at the end of the year because there's already gonna be a bunch of big stuff happening
between this and Star Wars
Leave all your requests for Deadpool videos in the comments below especially if you have comic books specific videos for Deadpool
But what'll happen is I have a thor ragnarok
Deleted scenes video that I'm working on there's also some new black panther, so I'll try to post that stuff before arrow starts tonight
But new arrow episode too. Even though this is Deadpool stuff
I'll just add the star wars ticket giveaway to this too because that's like the next big movie that's coming out so all you have
To do to enter that is be a subscriber leave a comment on this video
I'll announce a new winner when I post new Star Wars or Marvel in the next couple of days so while you wait for everything
Click here for the Deadpool teaser trailer, and you can click here for all my Thor Ragnarok Easter eggs
Thank you so much for watching. Everybody stay awesome. I'll see you guys tonight